yeah hello welcome to this video FM our
cards my opponent from Israel so we get
a an English opening
a little bit since before right yeah I
just had a complete brain lapse like I
hope you should before is that a move I
going for ya okay so an important point
is ok now it's not relevant anymore it's
not to castle too early sh5 is really a
kind of dangerous in these structures Oh
wants to take that would be quite happy
about No ok so g4 is probably not great
you might even take so i would have to
prepare this a little bit better so f is
actually on here unless there's some
Bishop before something like that which
could be quite embarrassing I can
totally pinned maybe
[Music]
the night I'm just calculating is so
crazy when I how do you tell you ok this
is preparing g4 I know it looks a little
bit weird but i think a kit couldn't
have played you for otherwise and i
really want to get this in june find an
f4 it stirred
[Music]
okay Bishop g5 is an idea but currently
90 x 24 is refuting this quite
convincingly sorry
yes that's an interesting position take
that okay hope in that good here hmm
getting the night over one thing is
d 4 square d for bishop moves nyjah 3 is
slightly slightly loose
[Music]
[Music]
let's do this first let's get to get
more pieces in play I want to cover
deform preventing Bishop deform there
should be five i'm also out out here for
g5 sorry my voice is a bit off so g5
right yeah or with the Queen you can
take it with a queen
I would have liked to keep the tax
credit but I'm winning this Pawnee and
his king is exposed so high 75 sorry my
voice is really off after playing many
games in a row how to do that I think
this Saudi 5v5
going from we should before end and then
trying to attack
he is write a check so night at five
check I actually just wondered what's
blonde at this one okay 96 now or no no
one more reason don't really see a great
move from here maybe takes look at five
huh
a very long time morning whoa that's
possible
he just moves the king huh
No
it takes the night takes should be very
strong push 56 Bishop g6 also is a
problem for black you should take I can
actually take on itself
[Music]
each age 8 is the thing I don't see a
mate though my typical problem check
check check I saw it at the end there's
now a couple of mates going on this
gentleman checkmate who tough game and 2
3 99 just 11 point short of the of the
rating that I want ok tough game but I
think interesting game let's see let's
see how it went yeah this is a this is
closest our position is quite quite
interesting we've got all pieces on the
board and it's tough to play here
originally I wanted to go F form and
then I spotted that Bishop before it's
quite awkward engine please hold 3 a 4
ok so that was I was not losing here it
looked weird then I looked at g4 but
here i can actually high profile I mean
here this is I thought this jack and i
hated this ok and ultimately I went with
this which was probably right yeah and
this I liked him for white computer
gives like a slider shut its it's
extremely tough to play yeah so he
didn't want this so I gave me
[Music]
give me that pawn 93 is no no default
preferred by the engine so this chick
said why does indeed better here okay so
I wasn't completely over them with my
assessment 95 I just want to check if I
have blundered something because you can
never really play the the best moves all
the time even though I am I played good
ones mostly yeah and here it just made
sense water dinner solidly check
checkmate yeah yeah maybe I think that
was a that was a quite quite decent game
there was no big blunder in them and
short White's chances on the King side
once you have organized this correctly
a3 looks a bit ugly but it's the right
prep move for further action okay thanks
for watching